today on the matt walsh show we will
follow the saga of only fans first it
announced that it was getting rid of
pornographic content but after a huge
backlash from the public the company has
backtracked what does this whole drama
tell us about our culture we'll talk
about that today also the rapper busta
rhymes delivers one of the best
anti-mask speeches we've seen yet he did
this at a concert we'll play that i
think it's pretty great and the
republican governor of south dakota says
that she will not prevent employers from
imposing vaccine mandates and also
planned parenthood gets into the trans
hormone therapy
replacement game plus in our daily
cancellation we will ask the very
important question is air conditioning
racist the answer might surprise you all
of that and more today on the matt wall
show
about a week ago only fans announced
that it was banning sexually explicit
content now when i first heard that i
was relieved but also confused because i
didn't realize that my local ceiling fan
store sold porn in the first place
and i apologize profusely for that jug i
just been waiting for a week to use it
and decided to finally put it at the
very beginning of the show as a means of
introducing what is actually a pretty
serious conversation it's not my fault
though when the pun is there i have to
take it that's my solemn obligation as a
dad anyway
back to only fans the real only fans the
site which officially bills itself as a
platform for content creators to
interact with their fans but which
actually isn't has always been a direct
consumer porn site where the average
woman can pour herself out to paid
subscribers
last week when you heard those whales of
anguish emanating from our nation's
ever-growing community of prostitutes
and sex-starved losers
that was the moment
when only fans announced that it would
be banning pornographic material from
its platform now the move came as a
surprise to almost everyone myself
included because only fans
banning porn is like texas roadhouse
going vegan you know it's just not what
you expect they're abandoning their core
business model the difference of course
is that texas roadhouse's core business
is good and delicious while only fans is
bad
the ceo of only fans later clarified
that he was forced to make the change
because various banks he said were
refusing to work with him worried that
their you know reputation was at risk if
they were partnering with a smut peddler
like himself
and this was all a surprise but it was
an objectively positive
development a good surprise
most people though didn't see it as
positive however as mentioned those
prostitutes and sex starved losers were
not happy
the latter group cried out in protest
distraught that instead of being able to
access pornography on seven billion
different websites now they could only
access it on six billion nine hundred
ninety nine million nine hundred ninety
nine thousand nine hundred ninety
i mean whatever will they do
we've seen time and time again
porn fans
cannot handle even the slightest
obstruction the mildest impediment the
smallest hurdle being placed in their
path as they pursue their cherished
hobby of watching strangers have sex on
the internet they can't handle it
if you so much as suggest
that uh that pornhub should have a
little box you have to check to at least
confirm that you're over the age of 18
most porn fans will say no no that's an
infringement on my rights don't make me
check a box first
but the loudest voices speaking out
against the policy change were the
legions of prostitutes who depend on
only fans to facilitate their
self-depict debasement and
self-objectification in exchange for
money where else would they go if they
wanted to charge strangers 15 bucks a
pop to stare at their genitals well it
seems they could go almost anywhere
including down to the street corner
given that this is again
simply prostitution
but they preferred only fans and out of
all the websites where strangers might
stare at their genitals only fans was
the classiest and most prestigious
over the following week therefore the
media published many tearful profiles of
hard-working decent
middle-aged women who tragedy of
tragedies may now be forced to get real
jobs truly unthinkable
here's uh one such report i think a
representative sample from people.com
it said this is from a couple days ago
that only fans creators are continuing
to grapple with their uncertain future
in the days following the platform's
controversial decision to ban sexually
explicit conduct let's pause there for a
minute and say it's controversial to not
sell
to to not have sexually explicit content
is controversial
anyway it says model and life coach
courtney tilia tells people she is one
of the creators who was blindsided by
the new band which is expected to go
into effect in october a 34 year old
mother of four tilia says she taught
special education for six years before
her battle with depression led her to
transition into a modeling and fitness
career two and a half years ago she
launched her only fan's page and says
that she now earns a six-figure salary
it was shocking tilia says of the band
announcement which she found to be very
sudden and vague
she adds it also feels leaves us feeling
not so great because we were the ones
who built that platform and made it into
what it is today
we made it a brand that people know and
to go back on the people who built it
it's pretty awful she continues
yes courtney was depressed
we all know the best cure for depression
is to turn yourself into an object for
creepy men to consume
that's why porn stars and prostitutes
have such famously low rates of
substance abuse depression and suicide
a real mentally and emotionally stable
bunch as we all know
courtney continues
i fell in love with it
i fell in love with being liberated and
being able to share myself in different
ways
different ways
i started this for my own expression i
had no idea there was so much money to
be made in it as there is
tilia who first spoke to tmz notes that
the money she's made from the platform
has allowed her to buy a house provide
for her children and travel extensively
truly you know i can think of no plight
as tragic as that of a 34 year old life
coach named courtney who wants to be
able to get naked for strangers so that
she can go she can take nicer
vacations and only fans had just taken
that away from her
i mean forget about the americans
trapped in afghanistan courtney is the
one who really deserves our sympathy
just a terrible story
poor courtney
but middle-aged the middle-aged
courtneys of the world are now rejoicing
because today
the news broke that only fans has
changed
its mind variety has the news which came
out this morning they say only fans
dropped plans to ban pornography from
its service less than a week after the
uk content creator subscription site had
announced the change citing the need to
comply with policies of banking partners
on wednesday the company said it's
secured assurances necessary to support
our diverse creator community suggesting
that it has new agreements with banks to
pay only fans content creators including
those who share sexually explicit
material
quote thank you to everyone for making
your voices heard we have secured
assurances necessary to support our
diverse creator community and have
suspended the planned october 1st policy
change
onlyfan stands for inclusion and we will
continue to provide a home for all
creators
well
all creators except those with
self-respect or an ounce of dignity they
will continue to be excluded from the
only fans community which is no loss to
them i suppose
now after all of this drama
we're back where we started
in our society today
even just the very small
positive step
of one porn site being pressured to stop
selling smut
proved to be
too large a leap
just one site
it's all quite pathetic and a little
depressing but i think there are a few
worthwhile points to make in relation to
all of this
and i'll focus on just two of them
the first one is that we see how
thanks to only fans and the porn
industry more broadly
prostitution has been normalized
the left wants us has always wanted us
to view sex work as real work and
prominent people including alexandria
queso cortez and other democrats have
chanted this slogan sex work is real
work
all of the heartfelt accounts we've seen
in the media especially in the past week
about well-off middle-aged mothers who
sell their bodies to strangers only
demonstrates how normalized this has all
become
our culture has certainly bought into
the notion that sex work is real work
but no matter how many people buy into
it
it will remain as untrue as it has
always been
real work
involves utilizing a skill or performing
a service
now if this is being done as a job or a
career then the skill or service is sold
in exchange for monetary compensation
but there is no skill or talent or art
involved in taking your clothes off on
camera
showing people your genitals
in that case the thing being sold
is not a skill
you know if you're a construction worker
you're using your body
yes in the performance of your job but
what you're selling is your skill
at being a construction worker
at building things
in the case of someone doing porn or
prostitution the thing being sold is
your body
you're not using your body to perform a
skill because there is no skill but
rather simply you're selling your body
itself your body becomes the product
you make yourself literally yourself
into an object to be consumed you
degrade yourself for the pleasure of
faceless strangers this is not work it
is humiliation
that you are a partner in your own
humiliation doesn't change it and
certainly doesn't make it valid or noble
one other point going back to the
consumers
um i called them sex-starved losers
before and uh the starved part is an
important qualifier because
people who watch porn all day
are not sex crazed or sex obsessed as
they are often accused
no they are sexless
deprived
starved
many studies have shown how people in
our culture today are having fewer
romantic relationships fewer people are
getting married young people are even
having less premarital sex and that
latter point may seem in some ways like
a positive development
except that they aren't rejecting sex in
the name of chastity
they've instead just replaced it with
the internet
they have replaced human contact human
relationship with voyeurism
and i'm here to tell any young men who
have made this trade or young women for
that matter and plenty have as well
that it is not a good deal you're
getting robbed
you're robbing yourself
now you may feel that you're satisfying
your romantic impulses you may feel that
you're fulfilling the human need for
eros which is erotic romantic love
by sitting on your computer and watching
other people have sexual encounters
but you're not satisfying or fulfilling
anything
which is why you're depressed and in
despair and lonely and unhappy and
addicted to this thing that in reality
you hate
that's why you're so defensive about it
see if you tried to come to me
and mock me for being married
i would just laugh at you
i mean i'm fully confident in my
decision to choose a living breathing
flesh and blood woman over a computer
image
i don't need to defend it
but when i criticize porn
you become extremely angry
the way that a heroin addict might get
angry if you stage an intervention
so what does that tell you
well it tells you what you already know
which is that this stuff is poison and
it's making you miserable
our culture tells you that it's healthy
and it's good and it's normal
but that's a lie
another lie
one of many
now let's get to our five headlines
let's talk now about bambi you know
i know as well as anyone that hr issues
can destroy your company well i don't
really know that from experience at all
but i know it because it's on the sheet
that i'm reading right now and it seems
correct because you got wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations all of
that also hr manager salaries aren't
cheap an average of seventy thousand
dollars a year you're gonna be spending
that's why you need bambi spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e it was created specifically
for small businesses you can get a
dedicated hr manager you can craft hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99 a month that's gonna be a
lot cheaper than the seventy thousand
dollars a year do the math on that
because i can't with bambi you can
change hr from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real time chat from onboarding to
terminations they customize your
policies to fit your business and they
help to manage your employees on a
day-to-day basis all for just 99 a month
so go now to bambi.com walsh right now
and schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com welsh
you know we uh discussed
yesterday the very troubling trend
called the milk crate challenge where
people stack together milk crates to
make a kind of a pyramid
and then try to walk up and over it and
usually they fall and land in horrifying
sort of pretzel-like shapes and doctors
are warning about this trend the media
is very concerned and it's very bad it's
terrible
um we played a few of the videos
yesterday but um i had one other maybe
we should just play a couple more before
we get into the news because again
really this is about
education it's also i really want to
emphasize how terrible all this is
and um
i want you to understand what's going on
out there in the world
and if you see milk crates stacked up
somewhere uh i want you to know what all
that means so let's play just uh one
more of these just to see
uh really so this is what the milk crate
challenge is i want you to watch this
and it's very oh my oh right on his head
you break your neck doing that
and i don't know if you didn't get a
good look at that we'll just put one up
one more up here because that happened
kind of fast we'll play one more but
this guy he's like oh well that
now that is not
that's not good at all
the guy was standing in the milk crate
someone else came and kicked the milk
crates out you could kill someone doing
that
that guy could be dead
i i that is unacceptable unacceptable
anyway i bring this up really because
watching these videos
i felt
inspired
and there's a real part of me that wants
to try it
only because
i'll tell you why
it's not because i'm stupid that might
be part of it but
none of these people have the right
strategy so i feel like it may be really
really for the good of everybody really
just to protect other people i want to
do the milk crate challenge myself to
show you how it's done so that we can
so we won't have any more of these any
more neck and spinal cord injuries
because the mistake people make is when
they get to the top milk crate they stop
you never have two feet on the same milk
crate okay that's the strategy keep
moving you got to go with the momentum
and i want to be able to demonstrate
this and i had this idea of doing the
milk crate challenge i was talking to my
wife about it last night and here's what
she said to me these are her words she
said
you're too
old um you'll look stupid and you'll
wreck your face that's what she said to
me
this is the kind of
doubt that i have to encounter and then
our producers seanan mckenna put a poll
up
for you folks in the audience said
should matt do the milk crate challenge
and apparently almost everyone said no
so i feel betrayed really in many ways
i would think you of all people would
want me to do it
so i'm i haven't i haven't ruled it out
i do i feel i this is a calling that i
feel from the universe i feel like the
universe is just
it's my fate it's my destiny atop those
milk crates
so we'll see all right let's uh move on
to the real real news here
away from the milk crates for a moment
let's start with this buster rhymes at a
concert he's a a rapper who he was i
don't know if he's still making music
but back in the 90s he was a big deal
and but he's still out there and he was
at a concert
a couple days ago and he launches into
what i think unironically i say this is
a profound and powerful speech railing
against masking mandates and standing up
for liberty it also requires some
courage here because the the audience is
not entirely with him
especially because of how political this
whole issue is doesn't need to be
political
but it is so let's uh let's listen to
that
i'm trying to take our civil liberties
away
feels good to be back outside we outside
for real
[Applause]
it's called the god-given right of
freedom right
no human
a mask on
we can't eat food with a [ __ ] man
we can't even see each other's smile
with a mask on
damn no i come from a time where before
i used to even want to holler at a chick
with my face to let her know that i'm
into him
all of that energy gets blocked when
your mask is on
energy is important and we are all
conductors of good energy
we also got to be clear when a mother
trying to give you bad energy
you could tell from only the expression
on a face
i want to see your face
and he's right you can't holler at a
chick
i've been making that point from from
day one
i wish i had thought to say that in my
school board
speech first of all with these masks on
we can't holler at chicks
maybe it's better that i didn't include
that
uh especially at a school board but
he yeah if you get past the profanity
and everything he's expressing it in his
own way as a rapper but uh but he's he's
100 right
and this is also not nothing makes it
important here is i'm assuming
not stereotype but i'm assuming that
buster rhymes is not a conservative
republican
presumably
and yet he also feels that it is absurd
for people in power to be telling you
that you can't breathe freely
you're not allowed to go out and breathe
fresh air
um
if that's not oppressive then i don't
know what is
it's actually hard to imagine a more
oppressive policy policy than that
trying to control your ability to
breathe fresh air
and these other things that he focuses a
lot on
how we can't
pick up
signals that we're sending each other
facial signals we can't see each other
smile
and i know it's very easy when you say
well the mask you can't see each other
smile
it's really easy for someone in the pro
mask side someone in the mask cult to
say who cares about see each other smile
we're in a pandemic why does that matter
it actually does matter
you know what you know why it matters
because we're human beings
and and we're not robots
and this is an important part of human
interaction
it's a it's an essential part of of
communication
actually the majority of the
communication that we do with each other
and to each other
is non-verbal
and so removing that
not not even not for a couple of days
not in a limited circumstance
okay but
but indefinitely
inside and outside
having whole cities full of people
walking around with their faces covered
removing that i think
does profound psychological damage
and removing that from kids especially
yeah taking away a child's ability to
putting we could put everything else to
the side
simply taking away a child's ability to
smile at someone and see them smiling
back
does extraordinary harm
and you would have to have
a very very good reason to even consider
something like this and we don't have it
here
with covid which poses
almost no threat to kids whatsoever
but this is this is what we're doing
saying we can't breathe freely and uh
speaking of that
the oregon governor kate brown
has just imposed another mask mandate
and this is for people outdoors
and even if they're vaccinated let's
listen to this
today i'm announcing that effective
friday august 27th
mass will be required in all public
outdoor settings where physical
distancing is not possible
regardless of vaccination status
mass have proven to be effective at
reducing transmission
and are a necessary measure right now
even in some outdoor settings to help us
fight covet and to protect one another
you know the
most dishonest part of that well the
whole thing is
uh the whole thing is the the very idea
that you need to wear a mask when you're
outside even if you're vaccinated what
is the chance they never do this of
course they never give the data
i want you kate brown or someone tell me
the statistical likelihood
that a
vaccinated person outside
is going to
transmit or contract
covet
never mind the fact that if they do
contract it it's almost certainly going
to be a mild case of the sniffles so who
cares anyway
this is why all of this panicking over k
look at the cases the cases are up who
gives a damn about the cases
that doesn't matter i got news for you
i don't care if if all 330 million
people in this country have a case
that in and of itself doesn't mean
anything
if the vast majority of those people
just have a cough and and are sneezing a
little bit have a runny nose
what matters is the severity of the case
that's what matters
and for the vast majority of people in
the country right now their chances of
having a severe case is very very
diminished either because of natural
immunity or because they had the vaccine
so the whole thing is dishonest but also
where she says right now what's the best
thing right now
they've been saying right now for 18
months
right now only right now only right now
what is it not going to be right now
what what is the end game they've never
told us that
a year and a half in they still have not
told us the end game because there isn't
one and there never was one
they still won't say it though the media
doesn't ask
because the message that we're getting
from
places like oregon
or california or new york or certainly
australia and new zealand
and plenty of other countries across the
globe the message that we're getting is
as long as covet exists as long as even
one person in the whole damn country has
it as was the case in new zealand
we have to have these measures in place
so the end game is covet zero no covet
anywhere well that's never ever ever
going to happen
and i'll tell you something else they've
known from the beginning that was never
going to happen
the so-called public health authorities
they knew from the very beginning
they know what a coronavirus is they
know it's not going to go away
there are some afflictions and plagues
and pandemics
um
that we have been able to basically
eradicate but not not all illnesses are
the same
and a respiratory virus that travels
through the air you're not going to get
rid of it any more than we can get rid
of the flu
they've always known that
so the choice all along has been we
stopped doing all of this right now
completely or we do it forever that
really is it's one of the other there's
actually no in-between that makes any
sense
anything in between is arbitrary oh
we'll do this for another year and a
half and then we'll stop why i mean a
year and a half we're gonna be in the
same spot
that we are now which is that it's out
there it's not
uh
it's uh
relatively mild in most cases but it's
out there
staying on the covid end of things here
daily wire has this report governor
christie gnome of south dakota is not
backing republican legislation seeking
to ban so-called vaccine mandates within
the state
republican state representative john
hanson and scott odenbach are trying to
null businesses mandates mandating their
employees to get vaccinated against
cover 19 through the coven 19 vaccine
freedom of conscience act
gnome claims such legislation is a
slippery slope that could lead to other
dictates toward businesses that
republicans might not like
gnome said quote if we mandate one thing
are we setting a precedent for what
we're telling businesses they have to do
far into the future
the republican governor has though
banned vaccine mandates for employees in
state and local governments
oh mandate is a slippery slope if we if
we as republicans use our power
that we've been given by the people
because we're a duly elected government
state government if we use our power
to mandate something
then uh i mean in the future we might be
expected to use our power again god
forbid
it's a slippery slope
yeah it is a slippery slope gnome
and that that's what it's a slippery
slope to
uh
your citizens the people who elected you
expecting you to actually use the power
you've been given you're damn right it's
a slippery slope in that sense
it's not a slippery slope in the sense
that well if we mandate this then we'll
have to mandate everything
no that's where discernment comes in
gnome
that's where you make judgment calls
okay
not not every situation is the same
no one says that if you mandate
businesses have to do this then you have
to take away all freedom from businesses
altogether
and take away strip all of their power
and and the government has to take over
and nationalize all the businesses
nobody's saying that
this is a particular circumstance
where freedom and liberty is under dire
threat
and you can address that circumstance
with the power that you've been given
i tell you what i'm i am done and have
been done
for a long time
with these republicans who are too
afraid to use their power
what is it you want to do christy
i mean you didn't want to use you don't
use your power here
you didn't want to use your power um
over over schools to stop them from
putting men into uh women's sports
just like the republican governor
in um arkansas i didn't want to use his
power to
stop children from from being generally
mutilated
so what do you want to use your power to
do you have it what do you expect to do
well the answer is for these republicans
they expect to do nothing
they want to be given the power just so
that they have it
and then they want to sit there and do
nothing and wait until they're out of
power and then they can start talking
again about all the things they would be
doing if they only had that power again
that's the game for republicans it has
been that same game for decades now
when they're out of power they say give
us the power there's so many things
here's all the things we could do
and then the voters say okay well here
you go
and then instead of doing things all
they spend their time coming up with
excuses and saying well
hang on actually we can't do that
because x y z and no that's not gonna
work because of these reasons over here
and if we do this over here well then
the democrats will do it when they're in
power
no use for these republicans
who have made themselves useless
no use for christine christina's a very
attractive woman
so she's got that going for her
that as far as i can tell that's the
only reason why she was ever looked at
as some sort of
2024 potential front runner
the hype and everything that she's
gotten from conservative media is
entirely based on the fact that she's an
extremely attractive woman which she is
but you know you put 50 pounds on her
and another 20 years
i don't think she gets any of the hype
because outside of that she's just a
she's just your standard sort of
corporatist
establishment republican who's not
interested in doing anything
we got to do a lot better than that
gimmicky republicans
getting elected based on how they look
or whatever that's that's those days
have to be over we can't afford that
i don't care what you look like i don't
care about any of that
my first
qualifier as a voter is are you going to
use the power that you are asking us to
give you
if you're not then sit down
all right let's see what else do we got
here um
salsa from the daily wire says on monday
president biden got down on one knee for
a photo when he welcomed the wnba
champion seattle storm to the white
house
biden's neil which some interpreted as a
symbolic gesture in support of black
lives matter prompted response response
from latasha brown co-founder of black
lives matter
uh
before we get to that response actually
because it's a great response but let's
look at the picture here here he is
with the seattle storm which is
apparently a wnba
team
i know you and i for the first time are
learning that the seattle storm existed
we're learning that there was a wnba
championship and that they won it so
congratulations to them
can we also look at who is the uh the
woman there in the
in the gray dress and it looks like
she's got pants on under the dress
now we know and me as a fashion icon of
course i'm going to zero in on that but
what what is what the hell is she
wearing first of all
but more to the point we've got the
president united states kneeling down
i mean it's possible he just decided to
pose that way
seems unlikely i mean it probably took
him 45 minutes to get up from that
position given how old he is so
that would seem to be a symbolic gesture
in support of black lives matter that
would be my assumption i don't know why
else he would pose that way
typically presidents are going to be
standing alongside
the people but then
let's see how uh this was received by
people on the left and by black lives
matter itself
um
we go back to daily wire it says latasha
brown co-founder of black lives matter
uh said this is reported by yahoo she
said the president's possible gesture
was admirable but we cannot just have
symbolic progress she said of biden
where is that kind of passion and energy
and commitment to voting rights because
i'm not seeing him actually be able to
say that he's willing to do that
so
he
he gets on his on his knee
uh begging for approval
literally on his knees begging for
approval and of course as always
it's not enough it's not good enough
because it never is
all right next we have this from the
national review here's a really
interesting report it says plant
paranoid dresses itself up in pink and
calls itself an essential women's health
care organization but its business model
tells a different story each year
planned parenthood clinics perform
upwards of 330 000 abortions making the
group the most prolific abortion
provider in the country but recently
planned parenthood has quietly begun
expanding into a new arena hormone
therapy for individuals with gender
dysphoria
a service the group calls gender
affirming care
um hormone therapy has become popular as
a means of artificially suppressing the
sex characteristics of those who feel
misaligned with their biological sex
and now it says uh planned parenthood's
most recent report from 2019 recorded
more than 200 centers in 31 states that
provide hormone therapy for transgender
patients
according to the group's website that
number is even larger now
close to 300 centers across 38 states
maybe this will be enough for for anyone
especially on the right who still
doesn't understand why this is an
important issue
well why is planned parenthood getting
involved in it
why do you think planned parenthood has
decided
that now they want to start handing out
hormone
therapy
that's
got nothing to do with so-called
reproductive rights
what you're doing in in many cases is
you're making it impossible for people
to reproduce
so this is the
organization that bills itself as the
leading provider of reproductive health
care
and now they're giving out pills that
are
make people impotent infertile unable to
reproduce
which actually the more that you think
about it it kind of makes sense because
that's what they do with abortion
that that's always been the morbid irony
of planned parenthood is that they say
that they're interested in
reproductive health but it's actually
reproductive destruction is what they're
trying to do they're trying to destroy
the capacity to reproduce
and they're trying to destroy what has
been reproduced already
because as we know i mean uh
abortion itself has nothing to do with
if the word reproductive rights or
reproductive justice means anything at
all
abortion can't be related to it because
once abortion happens as i have always
said
the reproduction has already occurred
you are killing something that's already
been reproduced
so in another sense it actually makes a
lot it actually makes a lot of sense
that they would get involved in this
because their
[Music]
mo their mission
is to prevent reproduction this is
another means by which to do that
so i guess that um
we can't be too surprised
by that on this same
uh note here
here's a uh we haven't played a crazy
tick tock video in a while well when i
say a while i mean like we haven't
played one in maybe two days so here's
one that went viral here is a
person who identifies i think is both
trans and non-binary and they're
explaining why
uh
you know if you're a parent you
shouldn't be concerned about him going
into a restroom
with your young daughter he explains why
here it is
i hope everyone knows
that we need to protect the women and
children
has been used against marginalized
people
for most of human history these comments
upset me because it's anti-trans of
course but also it strikes me as
anti-your own daughters
anti-young people
anti-women
if you are a young person if you're a
daughter if you are a woman would you do
me a favor
please let all of the men in your life
know
that you can take care of yourself
let them know you don't need protecting
and that you especially don't want
protection
if it means erasing
trans people from public life
yes he says nothing creepy about that at
all the guy the man the dress here
says that no no don't don't worry about
protecting your daughter when i walk
into the restroom with her she doesn't
she can handle herself
that's what this guy is saying no no she
could take care of herself
and you know this is coming from someone
who uh
they're saying oh you're your daughter
she could take care of herself she
doesn't need to be protected you don't
need to infantilize her you're
infantilizing your daughter by trying to
stop grown
men in dresses
from walking into the bathroom and
potentially
abusing them
meanwhile this same person would say
i'm sure
that if you
use the wrong pronoun in his presence
you're causing him deep psychological
and even physical harm
so here's what he's actually saying
he's not saying
don't protect your daughter
everyone can handle themselves that
would be bad enough
but at least there'd be some consistency
to that
if his message is well let everyone take
care of themselves
no what he's saying is what this man in
the dress and the lipstick and the and
the
goofy makeup
what he's saying is he's he's looking at
you and saying no prioritize protecting
me
instead of your daughter
prioritize protecting my emotional and
mental well-being over the physical
health and safety of your daughter
that's actually what he's saying
and he feels
think about where we are in society that
a man would feel comfortable
it's one thing to think that way
but the man feels comfortable getting in
front of a camera and saying that out
loud
don't worry about protecting your
daughter it no it's it's me i'm i'm the
one you should worry about how i feel
because if you make me go in the uh the
men's bathroom i'm not gonna feel good
about that i won't feel good
your daughter might not feel good with a
grown man in the in the bathroom with
him
and she might actually be in physical
danger but don't worry about that worry
about me
he feels perfectly comfortable sitting
in front of a camera and saying that to
the public
he shouldn't
because that is a grotesque
uh
sentiment to say the very least
all right crucial report here from
buzzfeed beyonce and jay-z are the faces
of the new tiffany and company about
love campaign launching on september 2nd
in the campaign the couple is featured
in front of a never-before-seen painting
from jean-michel basquiat
uh his private collection and the
painting is called equals pie
for for the campaign the painting has
been reimagined in signature tiffany
blue and it was reportedly bought by
tiffany's from a private seller and
people are upset about this uh because
this is this cherished painting from
this great allegedly this great artist
is being used in a tiffany's ad campaign
so let's take a look at this thing here
there is the uh the painting
never before seen this was in a private
collection now it's being used by
tiffany's
and you see there that's the
now this guy
his paintings have sold for hundreds of
millions of dollars
and this is what we get from him
that is literally just that's my divider
in my binder in seventh grade random
doodles
this is at best the collective work of
the random graffiti artists who use a
rest stop bathroom stall
there's a bunch of people with a pen in
hand pen in one hand you know the other
pen in the other hand scrawling random
images on a bathroom stall that's what
that is
and if that went up for sale it would
sell for like 150 million dollars i
guarantee it
there's modern art for you
all right moving on now to reading the
youtube comments this is from evan says
matt if i only watched your show i think
all teachers are either gossiping
busybodies marginally functional
alcoholics ralph wiggum ladies social
rejects out for revenge or pedophiles
unfortunately that's consistent with my
observations too
uh
no well that's that of that of course is
for all the grief i give teachers that
is not actually
an accurate reflection of all teachers
or even most teachers
it's just those are the ones
especially the gossiping busybodies and
all that those are the ones who are in
in public
those are the ones getting all the
attention
which that which is why i actually feel
bad for teachers feel bad for the good
ones
same thing for nurses and doctors and
healthcare providers
the ones getting all the attention are
the ones who want all the attention in
front of cameras whining and complaining
and so on and so forth
but it's certainly not not everyone
another comment says matt i love
watching the other daily wire hosts
pitch the spg anthem especially ben he's
clearly galled at the idea but he has to
play along
well exactly it is all according to plan
uh john says the life and work of kinsey
is one of those things you wish that you
could unlearn
yeah you do wish you could unlearn it
but but uh
i wish it wasn't true so we didn't have
to learn maybe that's how i would put it
but it is true and this is something
this
it's a name we should all know and some
of the basic facts that i gave about
kinsey and also john money yesterday
these are the basic facts we should all
also know
and when it comes to kinsey i would
encourage you to go and do your own
research on this
i barely even scratched the surface
because of time constraints
but what i told you about kinsey that's
not even the worst of it
if you can imagine it actually gets
worse from there so i would encourage
you to go
and do your research because like it or
not and uh none of us do
at least none of the same people do we
live in a in a country in a society a
culture
that was
built in large part by this man
um chloe says matt walsh goes to
applebee's i'm offended
i do go to applebee's i go to chili's i
go to the i am a
unapologetic
defender of chain restaurants
i think you know i just thought i think
i've said before i don't believe all the
people who turn their noses up at these
chain restaurants i don't believe that
they hate the restaurants as much as
they say because it's a it's not the
best food in the world but it's pretty
solid
you you usually know what you're to get
and it'll be a solid like any time you
go to applebee's or chili's you're going
to get a solid
c plus b minus meal
and you know that
and it's not terrible
um
wyder ganger says kinsey by the way is
also a rather interesting movie starring
liam neeson i haven't seen that movie
but from what i understand it is an
enormous whitewashing exercise
uh i i don't think that from what i've
been told the kinsey movie does not go
into any of the sorted details that i
described which means it's really not
telling you the story of kinsey at all
dante says i can't agree with you on the
ashley babbitt case i don't feel bad
that she was shot dead you play stupid
games you win stupid prizes i don't
believe she should have died and i think
it's a sad tragedy but she was doing
something incredibly stupid and if i'm
going to be in favor of the blm and
antifa terrorists getting shot on site
when caught looting or rioting
then i have to be okay with this
well
uh
there's a couple of issues here first of
all
one of the problems is a matter of
consistency
that's why i said they haven't told us
the name of the officer they have not
officially released the name of the
officer who shot ash abbott
i could be okay with that if that's how
they approached all of these kinds of
situations but in almost every other
situation you can name when there was a
controversial police shooting they come
out with the name right away they tell
us everything they can about this person
so there's the inconsistency there
and also we have not seen this kind of
aggressiveness
uh this kind of lethal force used
against rioters in any other situation
it's only in this situation
and yeah she shouldn't have been there
she should not have been climbing
through the windows very stupid thing to
do
does that mean you just that justify
someone and shooting you dead though
because you're doing something stupid
the question really comes down to
did that officer have a very good reason
to think
that ashley babbitt posed a lethal
threat to him or someone on the other
side of that door did he have good
reason to think that his only option was
to kill this person
now we're not fully able to analyze that
question or come to a conclusion
because they've never told us really
what his side of the story is we haven't
heard from him
we haven't seen any security camera
footage there's a lot of information we
don't have they're not telling us
the fact that they're not telling us
makes me suspect
that
the information we're not being told
would not vindicate the officer because
if it would they would they would tell
us
if for example there was some kind of
security camera footage
that clearly vindicated the officer in
his actions then i would assume we would
see that by now they would have they
would have shown it to us
so we are uh handicapped a little bit in
trying to analyze this but based on what
we see
i don't see how you justify i i don't
see how he could have really believed
that he had no choice
but to shoot this person dead
especially when she's a woman
unarmed
i mean you can see her climbing over the
window so she's got nothing in her hands
climbing over the window she's
surrounded at all sides by armed people
this guy he's not even the only armed
officer in that hall on the other side
of the door in that hallway there are
other ones there there are there's armed
police officers coming up the stairs
behind her she's completely surrounded
it's really hard for me to believe that
he could have honestly thought
and reasonably thought that he had no
choice but to shoot her dead
he could have just come over to her and
grabbed her and thrown her to the ground
and he could have been as rough about
that as he wanted to be
so i just i don't see it personally
you know on monday the fda announced
approval of the pfizer vaccine as if on
cue joe biden decided that it was the
right time to urge private companies to
mandate vaccines for their employees
after the mess he left in afghanistan i
think it's an appropriate time to
question his actions and i'm not sure
there's a better place to do that than
on backstage with myself ben shapiro
jeremy boring michael knowles and andrew
clavin we're going to have another
debate uh and another conversation
there's a whole lot to talk about so
make sure you tune in for that it
streams this thursday at seven o'clock
eastern 6 p.m central on dailywire.com
and our youtube channel dailywire you
don't want to miss that and you
definitely don't want to miss this if
you haven't submitted your sweet baby
gang anthem yet
then you'll be missing out on the
opportunity of a lifetime your life will
never you will live in regret for the
rest of your life you'll tell your
grandchildren about the day oh i could
have been the
i could have been the one who wrote the
sweet baby anthem coulda woulda shoulda
now's your chance to write it and submit
it today this is your last day do it
all submissions should be in the form of
youtube video links and we'll be judged
american idol style by myself and the
other daily wire host but you the viewer
will be voting on which song wins so to
enter go to dailywire.com
sbg submissions and today august 25th at
midnight so do it right now
we have an incredibly exciting
announcement to share today deadline
hollywood just announced the details and
an exclusive photo of the daily wire's
first original film called shut-in
directed by dj caruso an executive
produced by daily wire co-founders
production on the thriller wrap this
weekend and will be available to daily
wire members beginning in january 2022.
the film is centered around a young
single mother who's barricaded inside a
pantry by her violent ex-boyfriend while
using nothing but her voice to guide her
two small children to escape escalating
danger it's an intense suspenseful
thriller that delivers riveting action
without missing a single beat the
trailer for shut in will be out very
soon and we know our members will love
this film we entered the entertainment
space in order to send hollywood a
message that you no longer have a
monopoly on the film industry and the
release of shut-in is just the next step
improving it
so you got to make sure you're around to
check that out now let's get to our
daily cancellation
in this troubled and extraordinarily
stupid age we can always count on two
things come summertime one is that we'll
be told by the media and various
hectoring voices on the internet that
global warming is to blame for the high
temperatures and
um the you know thousands across the
world are dying because of it and the
other is that those same people in the
media and those same hectoring voices
will insist that although we are all
allegedly boiling to death
we must not use air conditioning because
air conditioning is evil
why is it evil well the fun thing is to
find out what reasons they'll give
at any given time
all they know to begin with is that air
conditioning exists
and it was invented by a white person
and it makes people happy
and it makes life more enjoyable and so
it must be bad the writer eric dean
wilson is one of the latest to take a
stab at explaining why air conditioning
is a form of sorcery he wrote a whole
book on the subject actually published
in july titled
after cooling on freon global warming
and the terrible cost of comfort
now i can't tell you exactly what the
book says because i'd rather be
decapitated by a butter knife than read
it but i did skim a seattle times
interview with the author and the first
question in that interview i'm not
making this up the first question is
how was the public sold on the idea that
feeling comfortable was okay
yeah how dare the public feel
comfortable especially without asking
eric dean wilson first
well wilson explains that comfort is a
capitalist conspiracy and then he goes
on to talk about how air conditioning
has increased racial inequality and has
become and i quote a pretty insidious
tool for racial segregation
it's also destroying the planet and
causing temperatures to rise he insists
now here i am stupid enough to think
that the giant ball of gas in the sky
burning at 27 million degrees and
exerting enough gravitational force to
influence objects floating in space 12
trillion miles away is really the driver
of temperature and climate on our puny
planet but i'm wrong again
your hvac unit is really responsible
so air can air conditioning is racist
and it's killing the planet it's also
sexist we we've been told the writer
taylor lorenz has described air
conditioning as unhealthy bad miserable
and sexist
many other female writers have joined
the chorus explaining that
air conditioning is a misogynistic uh
plot basically uh because women tend to
feel cold
and ac units and offices are often set
at temperatures that are uncomfortable
for the fairer sex
now that may be generally true but look
sorry ladies you need to suck it up on
this one because if you're cold here's
here's the way this breaks down
if you're cold
you can always put on a sweater
if i'm hot
i can only take off so many items of
clothing before you start calling the
police so this is why the warmest person
in the home or in the office gets to
decide where the ac is set
those are the rules i didn't make them
up well i did make them up but even so
they are the rules
but we aren't done yet a recent viral
video brings us back to the racist
element of air conditioning and let's uh
let's hear how they make the case here
it is so many reasons i can think of off
the top of my head why americans are
addicted to air conditioning so many
reasons but the most infuriating one is
that our buildings are built wrong in a
great stitch desired stevens talked
about how was because of white supremacy
and colonialism indigenous people had
air conditioning through streams of
water built underneath the ground or in
ways that worked with natural landscapes
such as building in the shade and there
are so many more examples from what we
call vernacular architecture for example
wind catchers from iran a famously hot
place these were incredibly effective
cooling systems these traditional malay
houses are designed to be porous that
allow for cross ventilation here's
another self-ventilating house from
southern turkey so if the colonizers had
not killed everybody and learned how
they could naturally cool their
buildings we might not need air
conditioning so when y'all are like oh
it doesn't matter the field of
architecture is based in white supremacy
it's still like great design
it's bad design because we have to burn
oil to not get heat stroke to live in
these stupid buildings because you won't
respect vernacular architecture
okay so let me uh interject a few things
here
first why are americans addicted to air
conditioning well because it's great
it's wonderful it's it is one of the
objectively good superior things about
modern society
it is one modern invention that actually
has no downside
the only downside to air conditioning is
if you don't have it and if you don't
i mean i don't know what to say you got
to go get yourself some of this because
it's magical you're missing out
as for the supposedly superior forms of
primitive air conditioning yeah before
air conditioning people in the hotter
areas of the world would sometimes live
under cliffs or in caves
the lady in the video laments that we're
no longer cave dwellers even though
there are still plenty of uninhabited
caves in the world and she's more than
free to take up residence in any one of
them where she can experience the pure
more organic form of cooling along with
the pure organic bats and spiders and
snakes who will all be her roommates i'm
sure
but do you know what people mainly did
before air conditioning
um they suffered and they sweat
and they smelled terrible one can assume
and they died of heat stroke a lot
it's true that domiciles of all types
were built back in those days to
accommodate the heat as best they could
whereas homes today are not built to
accommodate the heat because the
assumption is that we'll all have air
conditioning like civilized people but
emphasis is on the phrase as best they
could
it was still very hot and uncomfortable
and gross and smelly
anyone who spent time in the warmer
parts of the world where air
conditioning is still scarce
can attest to that fact
but what we really see with this kind of
thing is how white supremacy
is so often recommended
by the people who are trying to condemn
it
now i don't believe that white supremacy
gave us air conditioning i believe that
credit goes to a guy named willis
carrier in pittsburgh in 1902
but if white supremacy did give us air
conditioning well then i guess that's at
least one good thing about white
supremacy
thank you white supremacy for that one i
guess
see the ironic consequence of tying
everything back to white supremacy is
that you end up making it sound like not
such a bad thing after all
the left now will blame white supremacy
for everything from air conditioning too
if you recall that graphic on the
smithsonian national museum of african
american history website a while back
they also blame it for hard work
objectivity rational thinking this is
all white supremacy
so does that mean that it's white
supremacy which enables us to sit in a
cool living room on a summer day and
have an interesting rational
conversation with our friends
that's not my claim
but would seem to be the claim of the
very people who imagine themselves to be
battling against white supremacy it's an
interesting combat strategy isn't it
white supremacy is evil and it's
everywhere and it's also the reason why
your home is comfortable and you aren't
dying of heat stroke
isn't this
bad i mean are you sure it's evil then
sounds kind of nice by your telling
the other problem of course is the
familiar one that the people complaining
about modern conveniences like air
conditioning
not just complaining about them but
labeling them wicked and racist and
deadly most certainly do not forego
those conveniences themselves
i could actually somewhat respect
someone who thinks that ac
is a nazi conspiracy
if they lived by those convictions and
chose to roast in the summertime or go
live in a vernacular mud hut under a
cliff or in a hole underground or
something
i can almost respect any principle maybe
not agree with it but respect it to some
degree if the person professing it also
endeavors to live according to it but
the people who allegedly hate all of the
technology bequeathed to them by western
civilization
never choose to forfeit any of it
they enjoy the luxury and comfort these
things provide to them while whining
about how evil and terrible all of it is
this is a far-reaching problem actually
in our society it's not just on the left
very few people really make any attempt
to live according to their professed
value systems which means that everybody
is arguing with each other and defending
world views that they don't really
subscribe to
and whose implications they don't
understand because they have never tried
to put it into practice
this is not just a problem with air
conditioning critics
but they are certainly among the most
egregious examples
and for that reason
i can declare from my cool
climate-controlled studio
that they are all today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
enjoy that air conditioning everybody
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel vadasky
the show was edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio's mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
dailywire2021
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
rejects european pleas to extend the
august 31st evacuation deadline instead
bowing before the taliban and the white
house tries to spin the situation as a
gigantic win that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen